magnus carlsen has withdrawn from the  tournament from the sinkified cup  he tweeted  minutes ago  i've withdrawn from the tournament i've  always enjoyed playing in the st louis  chess club and hope to be back in the  future  and of course the big question is  what's going on why did he withdraw  what's happening there  well hopefully we're going to get some  answers throughout the day because  as we were talking about just before we  went on air guys i don't think magnus  has ever withdrawn mid-tournament i  can't remember a single instance he's  lost before  rastam you'll remember  his he's had one bad patch  in his uh in his career what was it 2016  around that time where he  he was really struggling 2015 perhaps  yeah of course he has had bad games  lost games before  uh but i don't even know what to say